have you seen the new covers of
cosmopolitan this
this is healthy wellness does not come
in one size cover have you seen this
i haven't has it just come out okay so
it's a variety of different body shapes
of women there's 11 different covers on
it
um there's a rugby player on there who's
obviously like much more muscular than
usual and there's
a sprinter on there and there's some
plus-sized girls one of whom is in a
wheelchair so it's the full gamut
now people are overweight as far as i'm
concerned can be perfectly happy and
live fulfilled lives i absolutely do not
think
that fat shaming people achieves
anything but categorizing someone who is
obese
as healthy is dangerous being morbidly
obese
is not healthy and it has never been
healthy and the condition of
good physical and mental health
especially when actively maintained by a
proper diet exercise and the avoidance
of risky behavior
is the definition of wellness it's the
complete opposite
so i pulled up this meta-analysis on the
association of all cause mortality
with overweight and obesity using
standard body mass index categories
so relative to normal weight both
obesity of all grades
and grades two and three obesity were
associated with significantly higher
all-cause mortality
so that's a 95 correlation between being
obese
and dying sooner from everything that
makes being fat
the most wellness reducing thing that
you can do
cosmopolitan telling people that this is
healthy isn't just wrong
as far as i'm concerned it's dangerous
and stupid like cosmopolitan are
purposefully misleading their audience
so that they can jump on the newest
trend of signaling that their body
positive
but imagine if one of your patients came
in to see you and said dr chatterjee
i've been gaining a lot of weight
recently but this role model on the
front of the
cover of cosmopolitan said that it's
healthy and
well they're in wellness and health
to be morbidly obese like i don't
understand
how we've managed to get ourselves so
confused to a world
where we can't criticize someone for
their body weight which again i don't
agree with but we can't criticize
someone with a body weight because it's
going to hurt their feelings
but we can call over being morbidly
obese
well or healthy so that that
is going to set a trend for people down
the line surely that's the more
dangerous route
yeah look i haven't seen that and i'm
definitely going to make an effort over
tomorrow or the next couple days to
actually have a look and see what's
going on there
but this is something that i sort of
tackled in the introduction
of my new book which i decided to write
on weight loss or healthy sustainable
weight loss
for a number of reasons and one of the
reasons is that i think it has got
to this point in society as you say for
some people not everyone
where you can't have an honest
conversation i
am against fat shaming we can absolutely
have compassion
full compassion and no prejudice against
people who are carrying
excess body weight okay no i absolutely
but some people go one step further
these are some proponents in the body
positivity movement we'll go one step
further and say actually
it is actually completely okay because
okay can mean many things to different
people but
it is completely healthy to carry lots
of excess weight and you don't need to
do anything about it
and that's where certainly as a medical
doctor i actually have a sort of
split from what some of them are saying
i agree with a lot of it which is let's
embrace people with who they are let's
love people for who they are
let's not call them lazy or lacking
willpower or blame them there are
many complex reasons behind why people
end up being the weight that they are
that is there's there's
really good science on that it is not as
simplistic as it's made out to be
but we still have a response without i
think to say listen
if you carry this much excess body fat
you are increasing the likelihood
of you know poor health outcomes from a
variety
of different conditions so
it's everything is society now chris
it's got a polarizing extreme it's like
we go we we take a point of um
compassion and not fat shaming which is
great and take it to an extreme which is
it's completely okay we should never
tell anyone
who carried excess weight that actually
would be in their health interests
to reduce it and i sort of there's a
couple of paragraphs in the book where i
actually mention this and say listen
i get i get that we don't want a fat
shame
and i'm very supportive of that
but we also need to start to look at the
science and actually be honest with
people and say listen
i get it that it's been tough for you
and you've ended up in this position
right you're a great person your
identity is not that you are fat
right you have an identity that you're a
kind compassionate individual yes
you also are carrying excess body fat at
the moment that's why i think the
language we use
particularly the language we talk about
to ourselves which gave us a big part of
one section of the book which is to try
and help people go the way you talk
about yourself is really really
important
some people who say i am fat they're
wrapping up their whole sense of
identity in this idea of being fat so
actually
to lose their fats in some ways would be
to lose
part of their self and who they are um
now for some people it's not a problem
right but for some people it is
there is really good research chris now
uh i think if you know the aces trial
that um dr vincent valetti did
about a decade or so ago where he showed
a very strong correlation between people
who've had
adverse childhood experiences like
physical or emotional abuse
as kids and obesity a very very strong
correlation and i share in the book
a case study that i remember really well
this um
this i think she was 16 or 17 when when
i first saw her
um in clinic uh and i got to know her as
a patient and
now she was late in that maybe she was
18 or 19 and she was really struggling
to lose weight
she tried everything and i was spending
time
trying to understand what was going she
never was overweight before until about
the age of 16.
and then it turned out that actually she
had she was in an abusive relationship
uh just after she turned 16.
and i really felt there was something to
unpick there and we
you know i i sent her to a therapist to
get some up and it turned out that
actually for her what happened
was that it was a defense mechanism for
her so
she was basically i don't want to be in
this position of being in an abusive
relationship again
if i put on body fat she thought
i am no longer going to be attracted to
men desirable
less desirable i'm going to be unseen
and actually when we started to address
that unpick it and it was
it was challenging to unpick that
actually
then the weight loss started to come
sustainably healthily
in a way that made her feel good and the
reason i bring that up
is we should have full compassion
for her we don't need to blame her until
she's being lazy
and she's not following you know as
boris is saying you know do this for the
nhs it's hold on a minute
she was trying her best to
do it but she was she hadn't identified
the right problem so she was trying to
solve the wrong problem
once we helped to identify the right
issue for her
and then she started getting help she
was able to lose that excess body fat
and going back to your first point
around the cosmopolitan cups which i
will say to be clear i have not seen
them yet so it's very hard for me to
comment on something i've not seen
but i don't think we should be promoting
it and saying
this is healthy i think we should be
there is nuance to all of these things
right that's the word
that's that's precisely the word that i
was thinking about man like there are
gradations
between fat shaming and calling being
morbidly obese healthy
like it's not just and the fact of the
matter is that it's such an absolutist
media
circus out there that it can't be it's
got to be either
you want to kill all fat people and
they're worthless
or you have to be completely behind it
deny
any of the incredibly robust claims from
all walks of medicine that show that
being obese is not good for your health
or your longevity
like there is a middle point in there
where we can
accept people we can say this doesn't
make you any less of a person any
different of a person
but it would be much better for your
health outcomes if you were able to lose
some weight
and i i don't know if anybody i'd be
interested to hear in the comments
does anybody actually think that
cosmopolitan
genuinely believe that this is healthy
or
does everybody see through the glass
front door which is just
this is the new sort of newsworthy body
part
positivity movement that we're all on
the back of like i'm all for gymshark
varying the range of models that they
use
but they're not claiming that this is
the optimal health or wellness outcome
that you should have
the difference and the the line i think
that's been crossed here by cosmopolitan
which you'll
see when you finally get to see it is it
says this is
wellness this is healthy like those
words are directly under people who are
not
well or healthy i i don't know i don't
know
yeah it's it's you know it's so
interesting chris because
um as we were mentioning just before we
we
started recording
this this new book on on weight loss
that uh that i've written i didn't go
into lightly i didn't need to do it
frankly the truth is i didn't need to go
into this area like i
i you know my first few boats are making
really good impacts i'm talking about
promoting health well-being physical
health mental health emotional
health the easy thing to do would it be
not to touch the weight loss
right because it's so controversial
and i don't need to i didn't need to
yeah it is but you know why i did
is actually part of the thing that
you're bringing up with these
with these magazine covers is that
i've been seeing patients for 20 years
well i have seen
as a gp you see everything right you
you have you well i'm not saying you see
absolutely everything but you see a lot
more than
potentially other specialities and what
i mean by that is let's say
if you're a pt if you're if you're a um
if you you know you're a personal
trainer
you are likely to see people who believe
that actually working out hard is going
to help them lose weight
right they're coming in with that belief
system in place
and therefore you're going to see the
subset of people
who really believe that's the way that's
going to help them and you're going to
have your own experience of what works
and what doesn't work
right and that's completely fine if
you're a psychologist
you're probably going to see people
who've got complex emotional issues
around weights and foods
and uh you're going to be you're going
to have potentially a bias
around that this is kind of the main
issue that i'm seeing when i see people
who are trying to lose weight
i will have my own bias because i'm a
human being and i've got my own
experiences but i think as a gp what
happens is that we tend to see
people from all different walks who are
struggling with all kinds of different
things so we see
the full gamut and i thought you know
what
i really feel i've got something unique
to share here in a slightly different
tone and a different way that i think
will help a lot of people out there who
are being shamed
who are being made to feel bad about
themselves
who do think that they are failures and
that they can't stick to any plan
but at the same time are being told
and are thinking well actually maybe
it's okay to have a bmi of 40.
i don't know well hold on a minute it's
not either raw
we can be medically accurate
scientifically accurate
and have full compassion at the same
time
and you know the truth is that this book
was probably the hardest book that i
wrote
because trying to keep the the ideas
simple
trying to make them actionable trying to
get the tone right
was something that took a lot of time to
do
um but it's partly part of the reason
for doing this because i actually think
there's a lot of people out there who
are being mis-served
and are being made to feel like failures
and worthless um so yes so i mean i
don't know if that made sense or not it
was kind of no
no it really does man and i think sadly
at the moment we have two competing
factions neither of whom are doing a
massive amount of good
for people who should or want to lose
weight
you have one side which is making a
judgment on them and their worth as an
individual about their weight
and you have another side which is
giving them advice
and a level of encouragement
which is literally going to kill them
sooner
neither of those situations are
[Music]
fantastic
you